agora é só seguir revela nem e assim né
foi o segundo da chave o ato de pessoal
aqui quem fala é o dado que sejam muito
bem vindos a g6 você jurar um ritual da
marinha grande portanto gosto que para
fazer mais um ritual é um homem da meia
noite é 11 e 47 da noite no alto da
pedra
não pode acontecer o mundo tem que fazer
o ritual bem cheiroso nem o homem da
meia noite fosse eu ainda não sei como é
que identificaram o homem da meia-noite
méxico já tenho quilos tinha tudo pronto
sua lista você estou nós aqui no canal
já sabem inscreva se e ativo em si nem
para receberem todos virgem nossa caixa
vem crescendo muito cansado e joga no
lixo uma nova muito linda muito limpa e
igreja aqui olha aí pessoal aqui tenho
que ir na cama lei atenção integral
falso nem por que não uma tática para
fazer a cama e aqui embaixo de um
currículo
olha o currículo eu estudei parece um
grupo de 80 é uma zebra está uma fibra e
aqui embaixo pessoal um animal branco o
urso polar olha aí muitos animais na
minha canon é tudo falso tudo falso
amigo do ambiente e já sabem pessoal
deixei muito à equipe neste vídeo porque
o profissão só que eu comprei que isso
aqui é uma câmera 300 integral do que o
filmar vai por ser mesmo no vídeo e
vocês podem 5º andar lá na tela e ver
tudo o que a acontecer portanto se tiver
muito lhe que eu vou fazer um vídeo de
tabuleiro ouija com esta quebra e vocês
podem controlar em todo o lado e placa o
mal se fosse um livro tivemos diz filipe
muito além das regras para eu vou pegar
as músicas de rock só para ficar o homem
de amanhã à noite é muito simples olha
só materiais você precisa de uma vela
vela
uma delas a de um pedaço de papel e um
instrumento de escrita com lápis uma
porta de madeira 01 am
daqueles que esta queda está em uma
caverna já está morto e chiqueiro
funciona e precisamos também de salvador
já tem aqui olha e muito sal mas é
sempre bom ter porque é uma proteção
contra os monos net pn e nem se o homem
da meia noite é um demônio mas é sempre
bom ter salvo e pelo menos uma gota do
seu próprio sangue com elas e eu vou te
contar e technip carga seguisse um sonho
não que eu acho que tenho aqui picada de
um mosquito por tantas que se vai
resolver né
acho que o sangue é fácil ter as equipes
mas se você está jogando com várias
pessoas que eles precisam de seus
próprios materiais e eles terão que usar
os passos abaixo de corupá chegar a 18
mas sua câmera é só que o movimento não
vai participar se á então é expresso
nick fácil só que vamos lá então as
etapas etapa número 1 inscreveu o seu
nome completo num pedaço de papel e
coloca pelo menos uma gota de sangue no
papel isso e hoje eu não sei mas esquece
de si o papel do molho de molho comecei
a pôr nunca tinha profundo orgulho papel
não perceber o que só tem de escrever
que o nosso nome antônio ok pessoal aqui
tamanho antónio martins campos eu acho
que há certo imagine no ser humano mas
depois não é um fado e josé aparecido
por sangue agora espera eu vou render o
esperado e meio o conselho nesse papel
ou uma picada aqui olha outra aqui outra
aqui outra ali outra aqui uma e outra
aqui eu já te picar um lounge do pm está
muito grave punível do peta muito cravo
olha isso é tá muito primeiro dedo do pé
só que agora só precisa né eu vou tentar
colocar aqui uma filha vou cantar essa
aí consegui pessoal fosse ok eu acho a
funcionar por emoção e que nos conseguiu
só agora vamos assim my life in rock só
agora já entende que o papel com sangue
temos um próximo passo a isso aqui é
complicado desligue todos os looks do
lugar em que você está fazendo um ritual
para não apagar a luz outra vez era
tempo de culpa e que pontuava ser agora
para a sua porta de madeira e coloca o
papel com seu nome à frente da porta
agora é sendo uma vela e coloque em cima
do papel do o o hijab agora é só colocar
aqui o papel aqui o papel e agora é só
seguir revela nem assim né
só isso
acho que o vai não sei as próprias
regras e ainda manda ver a neve passo 3
bata na porta 22 vezes na hora deve ser
meia noite quando terminar a segunda
desde o 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 ou putz muito
estado foi mãe no ir por causa de um mês
e deu certo fazer este passo agora
porque é precisamente meia noite já
atinge 22 vezes vamos ver o resto agora
tenho medo que ela entre em si que dá
pra porta apagar a vela e fecha a porta
a porta
você agora permitiu que o homem da meia
noite entra na sua casa mas quatro em
tratamento e se na velocidade para então
fazer um vídeo já foi catarina sandy o
substituiu por mil
agora quando o jogo deve iniciar você
olha devem andar em torno de sua casa
uma tremenda escura uma vela acesa na
mão o seu objetivo é evitar o homem da
meia noite tudo custo até às 13 33 da
manhã a sua vela se apagando o homem da
meia noite está perto você você deve
receber sua vela nos próximos dez fundos
portanto com muito medo meu judô o
primeiro leitor piado muito arrepiada
seu parceiro vai ter o mesmo tipo que
não fizesse nada não vai comer o câmera
- o que falar mas jamais jamais se você
for bem sucedida em estender a sua vela
você pode prosseguir com o jogo você
deve continuar até às 13 33 sem ser
atacado pelo homem também não vou ser
preso dentro do circo bissau o homem da
meia noite vai deixar a sua casa às 13
33 você está seguro para prosseguir com
a sua vida ok tem que outras regras não
lhe qualquer luz durante o jogo não usa
uma lanterna não para dormir durante o
jogo maluco é que a gente não pode parar
agora
uso um substituto para uma vela não vai
funcionar
ok eu só tive escapassem gravel
definitivamente não tem tempo para ficar
o homem da meia-noite de qualquer forma
mesmo quando o jogo acabar vou estar
sempre observando você chegou só tu vai
precisar
vieira não quer que o mundo anda pela
casa ângela não podem pagar tem papel
por fim o papel fica aí você vê lo a
pagar tem que ceder em descontos não um
homem também muito mal supostamente se
existe alguém só ó ó enem não é por aí
gosto dessa coisa absurda
eu sempre faço é tentar o estado mas é
uma crise do que as duas mãos o meu povo
como essa porta então olha aquela
então eu ouvi que portanto utilizamos
dizia o fpso sua vida comentou brincar
eu não to brincar ainda só embora ó
papel alguém na sala tudo postou uma
cueca turmas último posto não fosse deus
é costume do sul
ae
[Risadas]
pip
nós ficamos aqui por uma razão óbvia
apagada tem que ser rápido porque estão
matando e atacar em casa agora porque
senão vai propor um tac tic tac é por
isso muito cuidado por dois malucos
mensais por até dois meses tudo isto não
viu foi a importação sem mira botafogo
sozinho no pocinho muito barato as
doentes
em junho estava em uma gaveta pois vai
conhecer o homem tá logo aí meu pessoal
sabendo que o homem da meia noite dentro
do quarto no momento também não demora e
cunene
o míssil milan e isto está sozinho
a china colocou
i ó por isso pagar aluguel hoje tomei e
desligar se isso tenta tirar a limpo
terceiro que se gere uma moto deixaram a
plantar e mandaram os ingênuos e também
no rio
assim sobe muito mas aí o piauí pop olha
aí dentro então enquanto não vou matar a
estudante do 4º ano do ensino médio enem
o menino tinha nem vai me sinto muito
mal no jardim e aí tem muita área de um
lado ela se expôs também não vem
agradando gp china está com os agora
após chutão
é muito assustador a casa à noite e é já
pisei na água colméia
olha a minha pegada tem muita árvore
está muito assustador
agora sim não mostro triste
ai ai dos que não não há uma cota para
pagar para ver e ouvir
quem é sua mãe para com isso a equipe
infantil do gauchão
o cara não reclamam por legal vai por aí
português do empurra a acreditar na
china 58 neste estudo é que o tempo não
vai fazer isso contou que enquanto eu
lamento que tony estava tudo bem com que
isso acho que isso é verdade brincou que
pode resultar você vai voltar às novelas
lugar tendo uma o pessoal já é uma e 20
da manhã uma idéia nova
já quase mim mas a falta que mais umas
duas horas em tentar aqui agora duas
horas e à noite chega atrasada
olha só eu como a minha mão não se está
proveta por causa da queima das fitas
falei só vou definir os campeões não só
comenta a mesma lei taxa de será a cena
já coisa que vale são miguel em gramado
da granja nenê dar uma volta e meia e
nunca recebi da rotatória da via e eu
gostei muito assustador
gostava de voltar ela pagou pagou vocês
televisão na novela onde não há pai
assim o olympique só que a bola vai para
já a minha filha já não é um [ __ ] minha
mãe pra queimar que ainda ia montar que
mark to kill you no nunca que eu vou nem
outra
não tem ninguém
eu não vou poder sair eu vou acabar o
vídeo
a queima roupa em troca de um lugar para
surpresas a equipe que o filho do homem
da meia noite também está bem longe
daqui aqui no canto aqui eu tenho
certeza
eu tenho um homem de 69 anos ficou
acredita mostrando como estão fazendo
muito barulho que esse cara ele é um
homem do minuto o que é um homem da meia
noite mesmo não mesmo assim o homem da
meia noite precisa fazer tanto barulho
na mão uma bela não espero uma luz
bicicleta do material e nem vai perceber
que a filha é o que é o pior nome da
menor tarifa foi confortável já
anunciaram nesta ordem para cuidar de
encontro na história um time de verdade
afirma
em 2006 também no exterior se joga como
assim mesmo tem q se não eu vou ter que
ficar até às três da manhã no fim a
equipe do sul de que o senhor vai pra
cama na bahia
chegamos a sala uma sala que cheguei
aqui já foi bom já se escolher outra vez
em quando e como fica minha sobrancelha
lei ficou cheio só tão chique quatro
pessoas que toda a casa da importância
do amor do pt am e mary anne mérito ali
mere olha só espanha vai acontecer nada
aqui é toda hora 1889 e mary lane mary
landry mary mundo no mesmo sinal e
contínuos bem foi um homem de meia-idade
solo feminino encontrados fazendo o meu
melhor também não 3d 2733 é o número do
demônio não você não permitir a múmia
guto fica aqui meu apelo não são 3 e 30
da manhã
olha aí faltando três minutos abordar
aqui junto estrela e caso o homem também
no preço é tudo mentira primeira parcial
nem corri porque estou muito cansado
1334 sua autorização
a sala optando então é isso só vamos
ficar porque os filhos pretendem um
estado já sabem que reis porém novos
inscreva se aqui no canal que ganhou no
ano seguinte prática nas notificações
foi eu sou tudo meu débito e só fique
bem aproximar